on the final day of campaigning for
cambodia's national election the world's
longest serving prime minister Hansen
was a no-show
taking his place as the man of the Hour
his son the Army's Commanding General
humane
widely considered as likely to take the
place of his father as a country's next
leader
their party's Victory is all but assured
after the national election commission
disqualified the candlelight party for
missing paperwork eliminating what
analysts say was the only credible
challenge to the governing party
the International Community has
condemned the election as a sham
Alexander it's there not just about the
procedure but it
representation when the you know the
political party are free to take part
into election
s Cambodian people's party or CPP points
to the participation of smaller
opposition parties as a sign that
democracy is alive and that an election
will take place the Khmer National
United party is making one final push
ahead of Sunday's general election
they're one of 17 other political
parties challenging consensus party but
the question is is any one of them
strong enough to beat the ruling party
in 2013 the Cambodia National rescue
party posed a serious challenge to the
CPP but its leaders are now either in
Exile or under house arrest and a party
dissolved the candlelight party consists
of its remnants
multi-party democracy is not about the
number of political parties it's about
the competition between the political
party and they could compete with each
other on an equal footing field the
government also passed a law barring
anyone who boycott the election or
encourages others to do so from running
in future elections
preventing people from voting is illegal
because it violates their rights to
counter the deceit of opposition groups
living abroad the government amended the
election law
opposition leaders who remain in the
country say they'll vote even if the
votes don't make a difference they say
they haven't given up on a free and fair
election in the future
Barney below Al Jazeera Phenom Penh
Sebastian strange is the southeast Asia
editor the Diplomat magazine and he
wrote the book Cambodia from Pol Pot to
hunsen and Beyond joins us now live from
Adelaide in South Australia good to have
you with us so authorities would point
to what they say 17 political parties
taking part in this election just how
Democratic is it though
well none of these parties will pose any
sort of threat to the CPP uh Hansen's
party
um they're either aligned with the CPP
or they're simply too small and have few
two resources to mount any sort of
meaningful challenge the only party that
had any chance of winning seats off the
CPP was barred from participating that
was the candlelight party which is
associated with parties
um led by Sam Ramsey Who currently is in
Exile so this really will be a one horse
race despite the presence of these 16
other small parties
all right so not a lot of doubt that
hunsen is expected to win this is the
focus more on what he does with his win
particularly when it comes to the
question of succession
that's it this election is all about
enshrining Hansen's political Legacy now
part of that is initiating a transfer of
power to his son this is something
that's been in the in the works for a
long time in Cambodia but it's a
potentially fraught exercise with
various power centers within the CPP
potentially unhappy with the fact that
Hansen is handing over power to his son
rather than one of them
um I think that there's a need or Hansen
perceives a need to inaugurate hunman
Nets Prime ministership with an
acclimatory show of public support
um and so this I think explains
um the extent to which the CPP is gone
to eradicating all forms of opposition
prior to the selection even though few
of those opposition parties would have
threatened it
um in any serious way
and and how key is China's support for
the continuity in cambodia's power
structure
it's hard to say it's very hard to judge
public opinion in Cambodia there's very
few polls and those that are conducted
can't be said to be particularly
accurate
um I think that the CPP
um you know there is a probably a
baseline of there has been support for
the CPP for its role in ending the Khmer
Rouge genocide and bringing about a
certain degree of normalcy ending the
Civil War bringing basic stability and
development to the country but what
we've seen over the past decade and a
half is a real desire for change among
younger cambodians the 2013 election was
quite close run
um and I think the CPP and hunsan since
then have moved to prevent any sort of
opposition Surge from happening and so
and then if I could jump in there what
I'm trying to get at is in terms of the
Internationals that we have an
international audience in terms of
foreign relations and the the support
from China vis-a-vis where its relations
stand with the west house how important
support from Beijing in what happens in
this succession process for the
continuity of the power structure in
Cambodia
absolutely vital previously Hansen's
government was reliant on development
assistance from the west and that
imposed certain limits on how far Hansen
could go to manipulate Cambodian
politics to eliminate his opponents and
to shape things according to his liking
but with Chinese support he's been able
to go much further than in the past so
ahead of the 2018 election he abolished
the main opposition party at the time
the Cambodian National rescue party
which performed very well in 2013 as I
mentioned
and the CPP won all 125 seats in the
National Assembly he was able to do this
because China provided uh economic
support but also diplomatic backing when
Western governments threatened to punish
the Cambodian government or to impose
sanctions of one kind or another all
right and briefly what are the main
concerns for people poverty corruption
corruption has been a huge issue in
Cambodia it's something if you talk to
Ordinary People you hear a lot of
bitterness about people also jobs basic
infrastructure
um these are important issues uh
particularly for the young there's a lot
of cambodians graduating University now
um that are graduating into a job market
which is not particularly auspicious and
I think that this is something that um
you know the CPP because the economy is
based so heavily on garment
manufacturing
um and tourism there's a lot of
graduates that don't have a lot of
opportunities
um this has been an issue I think that
you know those sorts of bread and butter
issues really are the main concerns for
most people but you know an election
like this where they don't really have a
choice
um you know it's hard to say whether
those demands will be satisfied or not
all right thanks so much for your
thoughts on that Sebastian strangio
thanks